In this class, we'll cover
these examples and many more.
Each week will be composed of
two lectures, a recitation,
and homework assignments.
Each lecture is focused on a
different real-world example.
We will teach analytics methods
in the statistical software
R. In the recitations,
we will present
another example of the
methodology and more practice
in R. In a homework
assignment, we'll
provide additional
problems and datasets.
Midway through
the class, we will
run an analytics competition.
We'll challenge you
to build a model
and get the best
accuracy possible.
At the end of the
class, we'll test you
on all of the methods used.
The questions will be
real-world problems.
Let me comment on the
overall goal of the class.
This class aims to make you
comfortable using analytics
in your career and your life.
You will know how to
work with real data,
and will have learned many
different methodologies,
and how to use them using
R. In the end of the day,
we want to convince you
that analytics provides
an edge to your
career and your life.